we're taking a trip back in time to the
first volume production Porsche with a
mid-engine the VW Porsche 914 after
launching the 911 to cater to the luxury
market Porsche desperately needed a
lower priced entry-level model meanwhile
Volkswagen wanted to jazz up its range
with an affordable sports car christophe
wonders what it must have been like when
VW CEO heinrich nord wolf and porsche
patriarch ferry Porsche made a
gentlemen's agreement in 1965 they were
to jointly develop a sports car for
beginners and in 1969 the first porsche
914 emerged it was soon nicknamed folks
porsche or worse faux paux the same as
the abbreviation for the East German
police it came in two engine additions
the four-cylinder VW engine and the
six-cylinder unit from the Porsche 911
which christoph confirms is a lot more
fun definitely our sponsor
the 914 concept promises a highly
enjoyable time at the wheel
zoun can auto Fonzie the detachable
target --top' with solid rhobar recently
debuted in the Porsche 911 introduced a
bit of fresh air the doors of the safety
oriented convertible still open even
after a head-on collision at 50 km/h the
body and final assembly were executed by
the specialists at Carmen and Austin
abook the body shells of the 914 six
were made at Porsche headquarters in
Stuttgart and it was there the heart of
the Porsche 911 was implanted that box
about the boxer engine is fitted in
right in behind the seats as Christoph's
ears can't confirm it's a glorious duet
of raucous roar and the high-frequency
scream from the cooling system
the 914 Sprint's to 100 km/h at eight
and a half seconds a second faster than
the 911 team which had 15 more
horsepower top speed is some 207 km/h
again outperforming the weakest model in
the 911 range and likewise when it comes
to handling the 914 can match its Big
Brother
I was on but the real Trump of the
mid-engine concept explains Christoph
comes around fast Benz Porsche
suspension guru volcania even claimed
the 914 six was more a driver's car than
the Porsche 911
due to its faster response I got mine
bicycle for that and it really does take
bends like it's on Rails
although when you do reach the limit
you'll know about it and then swings out
abruptly and uncontrollably so you do
need your wits about you
absolute uncontrollable as a and it is
conten all's it's showing good perfect
as I'm decided opinion is divided on the
design of the 914 some absolutely love
the minimalist contouring form follows
function but others can't deal with it
at all design guru Bertoni said the
front of the 914 looked like a car
driving in Reverse an automatic that's
yet in visual terms the 914 six is no
different to its smaller force so under
brother really conic except for the
little six there for discriminating
Porsche fans that's not enough
differentiation but as Porsche marketing
chief
bushka fan hunch Dean said back then
this is an object for people who love
understatement and christoph says he's
right on the statement even wake up
today for the design of the body porsche
designer heinrich lee largely had a free
hand
in the late 1960s the slick slender and
straight line no frills sports car was
light years ahead of its time Porsche
traditionalists liked the dashboard the
instruments familiar from the 911
including the central rev counter made
them feel at home otherwise the less is
more credo continued on the interior
door and here it is between the seats
and rear axle the 2-liter boxer engine
until 1970 it was also fitted in the 911
teen the transmission behind the engine
had to be rotated 180 degrees presenting
a big headache for mechanics due to poor
accessibility but it's worth it
two prototypes of the 914 were made for
ferry Porsche and R&D head fed anon pshh
with eight cylinder engines packing up
to 300 horsepower back then the fastest
road going Porsches
yeah I took a vomit stop
the only drawback for Christoph is the
shifting it has a modern 5-speed box but
the mid-engine way at the back meant a
long distance between stick and years
plus a complicated linkage so hitting
the right gear is a lottery the gears
the Porsche 911 definitely has its nose
ahead aaseesh item adrift at annoy never
Porsche definite teeth dinars of Honor
as for those family ties between the two
car makers between 1970 and 1972 a total
of just 3332 914 s were made with
Porsche engines the lower price
four-cylinder versions with VW engines
sold far better minds I'm at them
together with its little brother with
the 4 cylinder engine the VW Porsche 914
6 is the first large-scale production
mid-engine sports car in the world
around 120,000 units were built in six
years making the mid-engine mainstream
as opposed to being reserved for racing
cars so the VW Porsche 914 six is
definitely a milestone in automotive
history in 1996 the first Porsche for
regular car buyers got a legitimate
successor and the now established
Porsche Boxter roadster has stayed true
to the mid-engine concept